okay let's talk about that middle-class
famous tour baby those sweet sweet live
shows
about to be kicking into high gear it's
a stand-up comedy show with a little ayg
that we play with the crowd great way to
introduce new people to the show so grab
the squad grab the homies grab the bozos
grab your best girl grab your best guy
and come out and see us yeah guys uh
first date is gonna be red bank new
jersey that it will sell out get those
tickets and we're in seattle portland
kansas city springfield st louis
nashville come on then up there to indy
get your tickets like big man said it's
a great time these live shows are
bonkers you've seen the clips link in
the description do it
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah little show
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find it at the girl to be classy
parents are just a big old piece of
trash i'm your host stage foley coming
at you on a beautiful day we're down
here at antodi's basement she's upstairs
doing a little gardening okay i ain't
talking about tomatoes though all right
we got a crop of sourdes coming in a
couple of weeks my co-host is coming at
you from right next to me unamused this
week i take a shot i swing and i miss he
is the ceo of ru garbage bit of
international businessman himself he is
the prince of park avenue but always the
king of the boards give it up for my
best pal kj kevin james ryan hey gang
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you review subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube as you
know those numbers are cooking and then
the greatest website of all time
www.patreon.com
check it the [ __ ] out love that money
how about a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man
makes us all look good we love them you
love them give it up for t-bone mcmuffin
toby mcmullen everybody
all right
gang we couldn't be more excited to have
not one but two incredibly special
guests here with us today our first one
is our good pal he's family at this
point a very funny stand-up comedian and
actor and the star and co-writer of the
brand new movie fourth of july give it
up for jolt and joe list everybody i
think this is number five i think that
record i i think you and enter tied for
five [ __ ] ian yeah [ __ ] you no sport
coat coming your way i could tell you
that in finance yeah yeah
what's he got how many does he have
probably five or yeah probably right
around you i don't know you have to
check the stuff this is five i think
yeah
we love it we'll send you a check all
right please do those big checks
everyone i see everybody i bump into the
comedy scenes like you know those are
your garbage guys are really making
money now
the word is out
yeah i gotta center everybody fall back
they don't like success 20 for old joe
list huh gang joe did not come alone no
he brought one of the biggest heavy
hitters into biz here with us today uh
he is a legendary stand-up comedian
writer actor director and filmmaker
let's cut the [ __ ] he's got emmys
he's got grammys he has influenced an
entire generation of stand-up comedians
and he is the co-writer and director of
the brand new movie fourth of july
ladies and gentlemen give it up for mr
louis ck hey
buddy
buddy all right
kidding me thanks for coming man thanks
for having me yeah don't be silly thanks
for coming in man you're the reason i
have a black t-shirt on
i saw you like 10 years like that's my
move baby yeah simplifies it it does
yeah yeah the other reason i wear a
watch i swear to god you're the reason i
wear a watch nice pair of sneakers and a
watch yeah i wants this is embarrassing
this is garbage somebody told me well
before i knew you yeah that louis ck
talked about how you cut your burgers in
half i started cutting my burgers really
i'm not even kidding god are you serious
i'm dead serious
that's garbage i do i sometimes i cut
them in half yeah
like a big tall cheeseburger with a lot
of [ __ ] on it uh-huh cut it in half got
it yeah do you lay it back down on it on
its top or do you do you keep it on its
side side it teeters a little bit on the
side depending on the burger i mean i
don't do it every time okay but
something crazy like shake shack i
wouldn't do that yeah smash bros more
kind of like a
hotel burger when they come real stacked
up yeah yeah yeah nice i don't know if
this is garbage but shake shack's the
best burger i've ever had in my whole
life i think that's better burgers than
that but the i'll tell you what the
reason why i cut it is because the
inside the center of the burger is
bleeding
and the juice coming out of it you like
that that's appealing to me yeah what
are you guys i've never had someone
understand the show so quick in the
history of the show that's crazy that's
what this show is about that's insane
how do you get the burger cooked medium
rare medium medium yeah i don't like
when it's red an aristocrat okay
what do you do i can't see you going
you're well done all the way i'm a
medium rare no i'm not that garbagey i'm
a medium rare steak and a medium burger
because i heard burger you're not
supposed to get medium rare because it's
ground beef that's what i heard that
makes sense okay but medium rare uh
steak i like a red bloody [ __ ] steak
i like it i'm surrounded by medium
medium everything medium everything yeah
pink inside yeah okay like a gentleman
yeah guys congratulations on the movie
by the way thank you very much
appreciate it we know it's going to be
in theaters you guys special events lay
it on us friday tomorrow this comes out
thursday coming up thursday tomorrow
night schubert theater boston it's uh
premiering we're going to do a q a thing
and then we'll be on stage yes with some
of the cast that's awesome at the
schubert in boston and then that's
almost sold out now yes the beacon was
last night from if you heard this that
was sold out and then uh tomorrow then
saturday the vic theater theater in
chicago but get those tickets about 200
tickets left there and then july 6th
well first it's also in new york city at
uh the at the village east theater and
in la at the lemley nice it starts july
1st but then it's in like normal like
it's you can go any time a run yeah yeah
but july 6th amc theaters is showing it
all over the country just just on the
six whoa at 7 30 all over every almost
every state awesome the trailer looks
fantastic you look amazing in it thank
you louie bobby looks awesome sarah
looks awesome yeah [ __ ] fantastic
yeah it was a real family effort we're
very excited it's funny it's sad it's
sweet it's gay it's just beautiful how
was the craft service
was okay yeah we actually had good up
without yeah
we had a nice great meals yeah and then
uh louis rented us all big houses and
every night everyone came to my big
giant house
he wasn't thrilled about that i mean i
just paid for the movie so i'm in a lot
of debt he gave me a lot of money
straight today yeah what do you do with
something like that you write a check
are you putting that on a credit card uh
i mean a lot of that you make an account
a move the movie has an account okay it
is its own
financial entity sure yes
yeah pretty classy what is the origin
story of louis c.k take us back this is
ordinary story you moved here when you
were seven right
yeah
yeah not to ant
what country do you think this is
yeah
yeah i was seven about you're seven you
you're up in boston take it take it from
there uh grew up in boston uh
suburb in boston okay i never went to
college but during high school i started
doing open mics okay in high school yeah
i was like a senior though but uh yeah
that's when i first did it oh in boston
comedy clubs
and then i my all my friends went to
college and i was just working as like
in a car garage and other shitty jobs
and uh doing stuff like a stand-up at
night fixing cars yeah really you know i
wasn't like i mean i worked at a garage
where they let me do brake jobs
and uh change the radiator out stuff
like that imagine that you know i could
change someone's brakes i have done many
brake jobs i've inhaled a lot of
asbestos too because you used to be you
spray this spray on the brakes and all
the asbestos dust that's because that's
what brake pads are made of sure just
goes in your face oh gee inhale it so
that'll be what i die of eventually it
takes a long long time you might have a
you know class-action lawsuit
1-800 whatever yeah
but yeah i was a car mechanic and then i
was um
[ __ ] buy a bike messenger all kinds
of stuff yeah
what was the child
trenches
uh parents together what did the parents
divorced when i was 10 okay i got
divorced when i was
like
guys making moves yeah
i don't have time for that i got brake
pads
you pulling out on your big wheel that's
right i'm still paying her too
i got two kids i said you're running out
for cigarettes that's the last thing
that we saw that's right ran out for
crayons
candy cigarettes so yeah i know my
parents were divorced when i was a kid
and uh three sisters and uh
um i don't know what else to tell you
live with your mom
when i was a kid i did a lot of [ __ ] ton
of drugs at what age did you say like
12. yeah that's like a real
divorced kid thing yeah i mean i started
smoking cigarettes like like pack a day
when i was like 11.
that answers the question all right guys
thanks for tuning in check out the movie
smoked a [ __ ] ton of pot did acid did
you did your parents smoke is that how
you started dad did but not when i was
knew him because he had a piece of his
lung he almost died when i was being
born because he had a piece of his lung
taken out
i think he was in the emergency room
while i was being born like that's
trashy
have your parents ever been in the same
hospital as you when you're being born
yeah did you ever roll them up in your
sleeve oh they were cigarettes yeah i
tried it a couple times but i didn't i
couldn't carry it didn't stick i wanted
to
i wanted to it wasn't the 50s he's not
the fox
no but there was like matthew what's his
name [ __ ] uh matt phoenix matt dillon
was in this movie uh outsiders little
darlings
and he world and he rolled it up
everybody did that it was cool i wanted
to do that yeah he was something he was
a looker when he was young he was a
good-looking young man i'll tell you
right now huh the outsiders
oh yeah [ __ ] smoking that movie is
good for a few shots
i said the other day yesterday in a
backyard hang that tom cruise in top gun
is the hottest i've ever seen a man and
everyone just made fun of me you're
crazy i just asked my
it was on tv yesterday i was at my
parents at my mom's house and i asked my
girlfriend and my and my mom i'm like
he's hot right and they're like ah i'm
like him or val kilmer they were like
him all the way oh yeah he puts the
aviators on the smile oh freaky yeah
he thought kilmer was pretty hot too val
cameron was i gotta tell you in the new
one tom cruise with his uh playing the
football on the beach
with his shirt off [ __ ] hangs in with
those young kids it's crazy he looks
good
crazy tight
that's crazy some of that scientology
yeah
he's in his 50s right he's got to be
fake he has to be he has late 50s late
50s
younger or older he thought he was
younger all the right moves was 83 leah
thompson's tits
thompson's all the right moves was all
right yeah it was great that spoke to me
directly yeah but the end is i think the
end was re-shot and tacked on because
the end doesn't make any sense the very
last scene the movie's really good it's
like a good movie it's like you guys
pennsylvania yeah 100
and uh and he just he has his dream it
doesn't work out because of some
[ __ ] and he goes into the [ __ ]
dirty steel mill and it's over that's
the ending yeah but then i swear this is
what happened i mean i'm imagining they
they turned that in and the studio was
like are you out of your mind gotta be
more lighthearted so they went and got
they got what's his name uh
t nelson greg t nelson and uh and uh
john penn
no chris penn chris paul thompson no but
it was leah thompson and greg t nelson
and and tom and tom cruise
the last scene is the three of them and
it doesn't make any sense he's at work
and she comes and says hey the coach is
here and the coach says hey i'm working
at this university oh yeah you're going
to get to be the rest of the football
guy there isn't that great
and he goes yeah but he looks at her and
goes what about you
then i won't see you and she goes i
don't i love you
the end yeah it makes no sense and they
don't look in character it's like they
check they put the clothes back on like
i can't believe i'm doing this
like one guy's got a mustache yeah they
look a little tasty
that guy really died in the middle yeah
like he was already making top gun and
he was like are you serious
so it looks a little off i'm in miramar
yeah yeah what kind of work did your mom
do
she is a computer
uh uh software
um engineer she wrote she was very
specific she wrote code for a fourth
generation language which is like really
heavy industrial yeah she wrote the code
she talked talked to the binary where
did she go she went to college yes she
did she was very bright person she was
extremely she she worked in computers
when there were punch cards like but way
back when like i grew up with computers
like in the house because she was very
good at what she did so she would take
home terminals with these this cradle
for the phone you'd call the computer at
work and it would go whoosh
and she'd put it in the anyway and she
was crazy yeah she was very good where
you think you got your knack for you
well her father i mean her brother my
uncle jack was still alive my mom's
passed away but jack was a engineer in
the navy he was a seabee
he went to annapolis
they were dirt farm
dirt poor farm kids from michigan
my mom and her and her brother but they
just thought they were smart they
education to themselves out of there
okay well my mom raised this alone my
dad was a mexican uh economist
okay
and so that's not a huge [ __ ] history
we're tanking down here yeah yeah it
sounds like a cartel member to be honest
yeah yeah yeah but so my dad uh
but they met they were both like in
college when they met and okay so he was
over here going to college where'd your
mom go to college again she went to well
she was in michigan but she went to
michigan but she university of yeah damn
that's pretty good then she went to ohio
state though she went to the two rivals
because she had a boyfriend in ohio
state and she thought they were going to
get married but he just got he was just
drinking and having a good time and she
liked serious people so she moved to
she went to harvard uh like summer
school summer school like she just went
there to take some courses
and my dad was there going to business
school damn my dad came from a very high
pressure family in mexico okay his
father put he had nine
kids and they all got doctorates like
they were all about education
so
so they get divorced that's it you don't
see your dad no my dad was around but
not a big part my mom raised us right
hey my dad didn't have an income really
ever he just didn't didn't work out for
him
and my mom raised a single mom
working every day in a house or an
apartment
half a house rented half of a house
there's little people upstairs where it
does like one of those three decker
jones yeah like that it was true but it
was like that yeah yeah was the owner
upstairs or was it no upstairs was
another tenant yeah used to when we
first moved there was the owner nice guy
mr um john panagako what was his name
[Laughter]
but yeah so they they uh and we lived
like a block from the mass turnpike was
behind that hiss of the turnpike and
there was a freight train all the time i
used to actually like that yeah put you
to sleep it does at night when a freight
train goes by in the whole house she
like settles and shakes well that's you
got something because that's great
that's not it
exactly
but then we'd go to mexico sometime i
mean i lived there until i was born in
dc but because my dad was working there
and then we moved there when i was less
than one okay and i lived there until i
was seven came here
without in english i spoke spanish for
speak spanish fluently now not great
i really i dropped it hard in order to
adapt uh-huh because i loved america's i
mean i remember i have my memories
coming to america that's crazy and uh
they weren't inviting in boston for
diversity at the time
well look at me i don't look like that's
also true i did all right
you were a cop all of a sudden you start
speaking exactly yeah
but uh no so i liked my life and then
and then uh and then in high school i
started hearing
local radio in boston
uh a lot of comedy comedy was big and it
was 80s i graduated high school in 85
and there was this huge peak of stand-up
at the time in boston mm-hmm uh
it was the heyday thriving local scene
and you'd hear them on the radio they
had this five o'clock funnies show on
the radio
um and so i started hearing i heard
steven wright was the first guy i heard
sure that i was that they said he's from
boston and i commit and i thought wow
this comedy here because i always
thought of comedy as this hollywood
thing sure of course but there's comedy
in boston and that's and i love stephen
wright still dude he's my friend now and
um
so i got into the idea of going on and i
found that i heard one day on five
o'clock funnies hey we do you want to
drop by you can do five minutes
and so i tried an open mic that's key
for you to realize that it is in boston
yeah you're hearing that there's a place
yeah exactly there's there's people like
me doing that you can just go do it well
i thought i would be like the new kid i
had this whole other idea like it's all
going to be these professional comics
and i'll be the one new sure i was did
not know there would be like 38 people
lining up
he lost
six spots yeah
he thought he'd walk right in like henry
hill huh yeah but you did get on when i
started started you could get on by
showing up it was actually not that many
new guys so and the uh open mics were
very popular in boston so they were
packed yeah and you really would
definitely get on you just had to sign
up
billy was like that you started
like were you like me did you take off
pretty good so i was so bad really i got
through two and a half of my five
minutes
and i to silence just like what did that
last week like that kind of silence
where it's not just like uh it's like
what is he deafening silence yeah like
they're like a little shocked you hear
the ice
yeah terrible oh man you hear someone
and then i walked off and i was just so
ashamed and the host made fun of how i
didn't do a lot of time
and then i went on one more time and it
went as badly
and i thought i can't i can't do this
wow but then like a year later like
right after i graduate high school
um there was a place in cambridge called
off the wall cinema it was a it was a
weird cinema with weird movies and then
okay so you get coffee and carrot cake
and watch a movie
so i used to go there to watch weird
movies and foreign movies and they had
they had assigned comedy saturday at
midnight and there was this weird guy
named ron lynch who's still my friend
yeah and ron did a show called comedy
clubhouse and it was all just offbeat
wacky just [ __ ] up comedians that
didn't you know some of them were just
so strange
and i was in love i was like i have to
do this so i asked to go on and he let
me and my first set at that place was
like boom cooked a little bit i was like
oh i think i can i think maybe i could
do this and all the comedians that i've
been coming already for a month watching
every saturday and all these comedians
who i knew their acts by heart they all
came up to me after my set
and said [ __ ] that was really good you
were really funny and i and i mean that
feeling
was probably better than anything i've
felt since
like nothing's been that i know he's
chasing the dragons that's right chasing
the dragon it's never as good as the
first never that good no sports anything
in high school
no i played pop warner football i loved
it okay i loved football i wanted to
play
and um i was big for my age okay
and then junior high school was the
first time to go out for a team and i
just stood on the field the day you're
trying out and i'm just watching this
guy just
you [ __ ] put like really cursing at
the kids you [ __ ] [ __ ] and like
guys and the seniors or whatever the
older kids crowding around younger kids
and spit on them
right and it was all on just like on the
field was just this display of
here's where you get hazed here's where
the coach screams at you and i was like
i just thought i can actually just walk
away from you
i just like football like can we just
play football
it was just so intense and angry more of
a carrot cake and foreign film yeah
a little bit lighter i don't even have a
vcr i can take apart by any chance yeah
it's not talking about the four films
around echo yeah
yeah yeah so i didn't get into it and
and then i started drugs soon after that
so that makes sense okay let's talk
about that butcher box but your box are
you gonna grill this summer are you
gonna be a loser of course i'm gonna
grill get out there on the grill get the
charcoal cooking the weber going and
what are you going to do you got a nice
grill you spend all that money you get a
nice grill what are you going to do huh
you're going to go to the pharmacy and
get [ __ ] uh
antibiotic chicken no what are you going
to do i'm gonna call about your back
that's what you're gonna do you're gonna
call butcher box grass fed wild caught
free range they got it all baby yes and
right now new subscribers can receive
free grilling bundle in their first
order
uh butcher box high quality meat and
seafood ship right to your doorstep
every month butcher box ships a curated
selection it's crazy of high quality
meat right to your home for free in a
continental us throw it in the freezer
when you're ready to start grilling when
you want to wow the neighbors show off
to the in-laws you pull it out you
defrost it put your seasoning on it boom
slap it out you're probably thinking
this thing's probably full of hormones
antibiotics no antibiotics no added
hormones no natural packed fresh shipped
frozen for convenience so you can save
time on your next grocery store trip
customize your own box or go with one of
theirs because they know what everybody
likes what everybody's getting either
way you get exactly what you want high
quality meat delicious 100 grass-fed
free-range organic chicken pork raised
crepe free and wild caught seafood
unbeatable value less than six dollars
per meal on average get the summer
sizzling started with a special butcher
box deal for our are you garbage
listeners are you are you ready you're
right typically i give you the turkey
now i'm going to give you the bacon why
because it's free baking again for life
for the members what are you guys doing
you're giving a store away plus 10 off
sign up for today sign up today at
butcherbox.com ayg use code ayg and get
one pack of free bacon in every box it's
crazy for the life of your membership
plus ten dollars off your first order
that's butcherbox.com use promo code
garbage claim this diana back to that
show
forget it smoke a little adobe a lot of
pot and my friends a lot of kids used to
do a mesclun we used to take mescaline
okay
yeah that's old school yeah and uh
big ones
really were big back in the day yeah you
ever take the lemons
one seven fourteen man yeah jesus and
others
if you want them that's the home run
record is that related
i don't know seven fourteen was bigger
that was the number one there was a big
huge pill i had a 714 on it is that look
that up that might be good there's no
and then hank aaron hit 7 15. there's a
new home run champion of all time and
it's henry aaron all right 7 15.
uh did you want to go to college
i did i was interested in it
and going to college uh somewhere down i
wanted to be a writer or something
mm-hmm
um you had to take a filmmaking class or
something right well so i just saw so
many i loved movies so much and i ate
them up i had one eighth grade teacher
who was uh social studies but all he did
was show us really cool weird movies he
just had great prints of he chose you
know 16 millimeter prints of weird
movies and they give everybody an a he
didn't care what you did
and that inspired me his name was big
note ty vignon was his name very gay
fella and inspired the hell out of me
uh and then high school
um i was depressed because i quit drugs
so i went into kind of a like a deep
depression
yeah
because i didn't have any guidance i
just stopped
and then i started again and it was a
rough road but i was doing [ __ ]
mescaline
no wonder you like the freight trains
you're an n a meeting in charlestown
exactly 12 years old yeah jesus christ
no i had well i had this one teacher in
sophomore year of high school because we
started in sophomore year in my high
school and uh i had
i had quit drugs and i got straight a's
the first like quarter of the year and
then i just went back to drugstore stop
going to school
so they brought they had a meeting
because there's a lot of shitty kids in
the school but they're like this kid was
smart for like he's got potential yeah
what are we doing so we can save this
one yes so we had this meeting my
homeroom teacher uh mr [ __ ] i wish i
always remember his name blair i think
his name was mr blair and he said listen
you can't do you're not going to go to
school i can't make you but you can't do
nothing like what do you want to do and
i said well i wish i could make movies
or television that's what i wanted wow
and he said what if i could help you
with that
so he went and there was at the time
cable tv was pretty new and every town
got a local access cable station
and our town negotiated for a very good
one it was like a serious studio with a
news program and sports so he got me an
internship at a local access cable
station
and i went there one day and they're
like we're going to teach you anything
you want how to edit how to shoot how to
uh direct anything you want to learn
we'll teach you how to do it and i i
mean that just i didn't i stopped all
the [ __ ] in that moment sure because
i was like that's if i just come here i
got your hands on this stuff of course
and then i'm not gonna [ __ ] up school
now i want to be a real person
so i got very serious i went back to my
high school when i wanted emmy and i
brought it with me and i showed it to
that guy no [ __ ] and i told him you did
this
it's the one chance i got to do that he
was like the one guy i could say that
yeah pulled me out of this [ __ ] he gave
me an opportunity but so and i was like
the whiz kid at this station and i loved
so i would learn because i i found it
because i'm a tech guy and i was a
mechanical guy hey you have like an
engineer's brain yeah i do i like tech
stuff so when you work at a place like
that
they just don't want you to break stuff
so i knew how to fix this stuff so i was
allowed to take stuff home i could go
take a hole back then a video
kit was a the camera was this big
just a huge
camera and it hooked up with a cable
this thick to a tape ditch
giant
it was so heavy it was so hard to handle
that
stuff but anyway i knew the equipment so
they let me take it home and i'd make
weird little movies with my friends and
then edit i learned how to edit from one
tape deck to another that's how i used
to edit back then great like you lay
down one shot at a time
and then if you made a mistake you
couldn't fix the middle you had to it
was a nightmare but i loved it and i
covered the baseball games and the
football games for the high school
really yeah like i knew how to run the
van there was a van with three cameras
yeah i was i was obsessed with kids on
loots what are we doing here giving us
kid camera equipment that's right holy
[ __ ] so that was when i had started
learning how to do that kind of stuff
yeah that was [ __ ] wild man all right
let's get into some [ __ ] garbage
questions yes what was the high school
mascot
a tiger not bad pretty good name in high
school the newton north newton north
tigers newton north not bad um since uh
nobody lives there what was the name of
the street that you grew up on
newtonville avenue
not bad yeah villain avenue what's the
the freight train
behind the trains
turnpike's not a good look no no
what was the name of it was the name of
the grocery store that your mom went to
as a kid star market star market see
what makes us shine
that was your thing those are things
star market see what makes us shine the
star i hated star market because any
time i asked my mom for money i'd be
like i want a little money to go to play
video games sometimes you go go to their
they're hiring at star market ah you see
you see real two boston experiences
between yeah
yes star market someone plugged that in
there
see what makes sense star market had a
thing called the uh uh jim rice butch
hopson baseball clinic where the two of
those two players
would teach you baseball in like the
parking lot that's a weird pairing it
was they would you had to fill out a a
thing and put it in a box so i took a
whole deck of them home and i spent all
night filling it out did you win one
oh wow yeah
that's garbage yeah that's crazy yeah
you're rigging an election at a stomach
election
and we you know they took you to some
high school and they play with tennis
balls not even baseballs
and jim rice was just like this like you
could tell he was like this sucks like
community service for him or something
and butch hodgson had a southern accent
and i was like why he's not from boston
this guy's a phony get him out of here
get this commie added a ballpark yeah
anyway sorry his long answer to the
question stock market now
uh where did you where growing up where
did you go to the supermarket stock
market as well no we had there was
trookies which is a name doesn't sound
this always bothered me because it was
two seasons cchi but the their ad thing
was his slogan was the true key to
shopping and so we were like no it's
true keys the true key
[Laughter]
for all your cold-cut needs
shaw's and stock market we partially
start marketing we went to fenway that
was the parking lot was this starbucks
does he know the story about the go-kart
i i think you do i think i'm a real
goalkeeper
my parents i was at stone's video video
store and i'll tell it quick because
i've told it before but you put your
name in to win a go-kart you didn't ring
the election i was seven years old i
just put one in i put one in i was seven
hopeless
they won they called us at home and said
you won a go-cart i was so excited
my parents let me drive it around the
neighborhood and i gave every single
name there's a picture in the paper they
made the paper we're in the newspaper
it's my dad my mom and dad and i'm
sitting in the go cat with my sister and
then they ended up my parents sat me
down and said we you can't have the
go-kart we're trading it
to
uncle
uncle bob he was my uncle brian's
brother bob
and a couple of screeners of police
academy we're trading it for a trip to
the bahamas and i was like great i can
get right into the bahamas they're like
well it's just dad and i it's an adult
pal insane
so
it's fourth of july in theaters now so i
told my parents i told my wife the story
just a couple years ago on the joker's
wild impractical joker's cruise and i
told sarah as a funny story and she
started sobbing
didn't the guy live near you wasn't
didn't you see him driving around in the
thing no i don't know about that but he
didn't live near and he was related to
us so he had to go cut so i had a
go-kart for a day i was the coolest kid
in school it's like your parents said to
you listen you have we we you have
cancer
but there is a cure
we're going to be in the bahamas
how'd you do on your sats louis did you
take your sats i took them and i did
very very badly i just remember i don't
remember the numbers below a thousand i
think so huh i don't know i don't
remember exactly though
i took an ap art i took ap art uh um um
an ap art history
um class test okay and i got i want you
know four or whatever the best would i
want to go cars
[Laughter]
i just didn't like the sats i didn't
enjoy it okay
what you would do now i don't remember
what i got it i know it was low i didn't
practice for i just went and walked in
and did it i got an 870 center field
nice yeah 11 40 not brat no 870 is very
very bad isn't it sad yeah what'd you
get list 10.50 baby there you go four
digits
something sounds familiar to me really
yeah you probably got it on verbal
that's yeah i think so yeah you ate
something
uh what were the vacations like growing
up
any vacations
[Laughter]
no we didn't go on vacations i went to
day camp during the summer that's what i
was like that's not bad yeah you could
drive to some place and you know to some
i don't know whatever it was stoughton
mass okay oh that's where i was born
yeah tough town yeah you collect any
chinese stars numb chucks ain't like
that when you were a kid
no
i like bruce lee when i was a kid but i
didn't collect fireworks
oh you mean any collections yeah yeah
anything or what were you doing um i
would go to the cvs and steal stuff
cbs was in existence oh yeah a long time
holy [ __ ] yeah
yeah i would go to cvs and shoplift
giant chocolate bars like giant hershey
bars yeah zippo lighters oh man i like
glow
yeah
fun those are my hobbies do you like the
smell of gasoline i do we just smelled
it we were just uh when we waiting for
the cab busy day
a guy was pouring gas into his food
truck yeah it was beautiful off a little
paint and you can see what the boys are
doing why is leg of the smell of gas
garbage
it is i don't think the kennedys are
doing it no
my favorite is asphalt fresh asphalt in
the summer no way asphalt is better than
gas that takes me back
away that is a tall no you're not good
cars all right
cars okay maybe
gas is pretty much i just think about
that scene in shawshank when they're up
there and that that hot tar and the beer
it's like very oh yeah i can just the
smell in that cold beer [ __ ] hits me
that beer looks like it [ __ ] hit the
spot yeah
do you drink if you have a drink what's
your drink
like winding down red wine red wine yeah
and whiskey i like
scotch good scotch okay good and i like
beer but i don't drink much but those
are the three things i like very cold
beer i assume you've had a couple nice
french wine yeah i've had i've had some
very good french wine like i go crazy
for like a very good
franchise how expensive we talk yeah
what's the most expensive bottle of wine
you ever bought oh a lot two thousand
three thousand something like that yeah
wow yeah wow it has been a long time
since i've done that okay i live very
differently than i used to i used to
have gold watches
that's a sweet shark yeah
yeah does that go under water yeah
that's pleasure
no i don't do stuff like that no more
but i used to go like let's get to this
you know
of course once in a while i'd buy it
have a you know heavy bottle of scotch
like a really good a good watch and i
keep that for a long i don't it'll keep
it for months just sip on it yeah nice
bottle of yellow tail these days
that's right
i think your finest box you have
um what if you're going to a dinner you
know at a friend's house
uh and you're bringing a bottle of wine
do you have a go-to what's what are you
what are you spending around there
anything it depends on the friend right
this is what we get into yeah yeah
there's you got the the wine that was
brought to you last night
just but you're just re-gifting just
re-gift the last one that brought to you
that's a powerful
toaster yeah i mean it brings me wine i
ain't drinking it
i'm not it's not gonna be what i like so
i just hold on to that until next time
that's real no one's ever had that
answer that's really smart yeah you got
to do that let's see
martin chris says he watches the movie
he sees fourth of july he says it's
fantastic i want to discuss how you guys
came up with it how you worked with
someone like joe liss how good he goes
i'm over my house i want to discuss how
you get this performance out of this guy
what do you bring in there that's a
different account
him or somebody i just really like
and feel or feel grateful to somebody
you know anything like that like
somebody who i'm like really want to wow
2005 if you can find it 2006 if you can
only find in 2006.
it's
french
it's um
l-y-n-c-h and then b-a-g-g-e-s i don't
know
i don't know what the [ __ ] say it lynch
bag yeah that's the [ __ ] boston
coming out they got you a
but that's about two to four hundred
dollars that's okay bottle flex yeah uh
or any kind of like uh margo's or good
okay son julian kind of things sure
any of those uh in the range of two to
four hundred dollars marcos are nice
julian
what do you like red wise you a cabernet
guy you're a melbeck guy what do you
like only those bordeauxs are just
really into french bordeaux's i can get
it
i was just in uh copenhagen on tour
and our our um promoter
he's obsessed with restaurants he's been
to all the best restaurants in the world
he's one of these guys
he'll wait months to go somewhere or
whatever so he told me copenhagen is his
favorite city for restaurants and that
he was sending me to the best of this so
it's his favorite place and i did a
pairing you know you get a tasting menu
with shrine pairings
and they introduced me to our
natural wine this is a noose thing yes
very new yeah so they start you with the
white one with a for they start with a
champagne and then white and then it
gets like literally those orange wines
and then you get deeper red as you the
meal goes on and they're cloudy and
they're not there's no filtering they're
not like refined or anything nothing
it's just like the grapes the earth in
it it's just yes you can really and
that's what i like about wine is being
able to taste like i feel like i could
taste the weather when it was in the the
soil so these things holy [ __ ] and
there's a gamey like almost rotten smell
to them like [ __ ]
yes
but the wines get and at one point i was
like i'm getting
like i trusted them and i'm like do
people what do people do to not get
drunk and they go no you get drunk yeah
that's that's the point we [ __ ] up and
i had to i had to walk along the
buildings i mean i barely made it back
to the hospital really you were that
[ __ ] i was blind ways i almost i've
never blacked out drunk yeah they're
serving your [ __ ] copenhagen [ __ ]
moonshots yeah
like sharon stone in casino
how's the rising suns
that's how it felt
[Laughter]
and it was a bad day the next day you do
ice in the wine
uh how many suits do you own
uh a lot but i don't wear them anymore i
had one tour where i worked right right
right yeah yeah yeah and i got them
because i i can't i wear a suit and in
10 minutes i look like
a dish a bad accountant yeah like a guy
who's had a nervous break i'm the same
way i put on a suit fit me the second i
get into a car or sit down it's [ __ ]
shirt comes up and out it's hard the
like a fat kid at the end of a wedding
that's right [ __ ] cake on your face
that's it
but when i was i was in san francisco
with my daughter and we went to a thrift
store and she found a suit that it was
like really cool almost fit
so i found a tailor in san francisco i'd
never even been to one and i said can
you
do this to me and he said yeah by the
way i can make you suits
you know you can get one just get
whatever you want and he wasn't
expensive but he was uh peter panos is
his name and i i picked just that day i
picked a bunch cool i decided it that
day i'm gonna wear suits he's gonna be a
suitcase i'm gonna wear suits i always
wanted when i was a kid i wanted to be a
comedian in suits sure
and uh so i had a bunch of shirts and
suits made by that guy like eight of
them
and uh he sent them i wore them a whole
for a whole tour of worst suits yeah but
i'm done with i'm not gonna do it again
any armani or anything like that you got
at the house yeah like from a couple of
movies i was in that they let me keep
the suits up
i do own a tux because i used to go to
awards shows every all the time yeah
nice yes you want to tie a bow tie
uh yeah i could i used i did it a few
times i'd need a refresher yeah i don't
know how to tie a regular tie
really
is that garbage i don't think you have a
tux mr list i don't yeah i got two suits
nice suits right ted bakery
but i remember hearing you talk about it
i thought it was somebody you knew i
thought he was like a fan or something
that's how trashy i was no ted you know
ted baker kid i remember when ted baker
was i don't know how long he's been
around but i think he was a new thing
and i was with chris rock uh in aspen
colorado at a festival and there was
like a lot of people there's a lot of
activity people were excited a lot of
famous people there and chris was huge
and i was nothing at the time and uh
somebody came up to us with a headset
and just said get in this van we're
taking everybody to we're just talking
so we just let ourselves be put in
anyway next thing we know we're in a ted
baker store and they had closed the
store for chris
and they said pick whatever you want and
it's yours and chris is a high class
classy guy
and he said just he said to the girl you
pick me one shirt
you pick it for me like that's the kind
of guy he is going through i just was
like
jackets
i said i want one of these yeah and
they're like um
are you chris rockstar they had to
unlock it it had a lock on it i was like
i want one of these because i was like
i'm never going to be in here
chris is trying to maintain this
lifestyle i was like this is burning to
the ground this is happening here
you have it it's a really good leather
jacket that's [ __ ] wild did you do
hands across america
no
did you go to live eight
no farm aid no okay
do you have aids
did you have a pet rock growing up
uh i had a mood ring oh
that's what we're looking for
any chia pets or anything yeah no i
think i might have had a pet rock yeah i
think i might have were you a captain
kangaroo guy when you were a kid uh i
liked the moose i hated captain cam gru
but i like that moves very much
dude those cards a lot of feelings 70s
were [ __ ] wild yeah i like there was
some uh
some well i like bullwinkle very much
okay those were very funny what about hr
puffin stuff that used to freak me
though so i there was that was pretty
good but then they had these offshoot
ones like um yeah uh
what the [ __ ] the new zoo review zuberly
zoo new
zoo review was there
a frog freddy frog yeah like how [ __ ]
shitty that you know freddy frog and
then a wise owl and henry had a hippo
and i hated them it was very kind of cr
i think they tried to uh go against h r
huffins with kind of christian ones
and i hated those
jesus the mule yeah
uh what was your first concert
uh queen
billy squire opening for queen
and billy squire was amazing too queen
in boston garden wow
that's a [ __ ] incredible show
incredible
19
79 80 something like that they did in
fact rock you they did rock me because
they said they won
outfit changes and smoke yeah and that
[ __ ] brian may and the guitar i mean
just incredible show [ __ ] that's
pretty clear right there
ever going ghost hunting
no
have you or any member of your family
ever claimed to have seen a ufo
uh no
i don't think so not that i can think of
no ever bought anything off a tv
um
i think i might have bought an album off
of late night commercial okay did you
have a columbia house you really don't
want to join i didn't join them really
my sister did but i didn't i was a
[ __ ] gold mine yeah that was great
they were idiots yeah yeah they send you
whatever you want and you just never pay
[ __ ] stupid you just don't have to
you have to not mind getting a lot of
mail yeah
you really should pay you guys should
you should seriously we're not playing
around anymore
red ink
but you didn't have to pay uh you ever
read autotrader magazine sure yeah yeah
first car
first car was a datsun b210 78 dots in
b210 was it a hatchback no it was a
sedan it was the best car ever i'm
always looking on ebay for once they'd
never have them that was
and i got a friend of mine's mom had one
that died so i bought it from her and
that was my parts car that's the car i
learned how to fix cars on damn i would
just take parts off of hers and put it
on my mind yeah we drove from uh
wilkes-barre pennsylvania to texas in a
hatchback datsun
best yeah big head broke down like four
times yeah well they were like made to
compete with like mustangs yeah so
they're actually pretty cool
um yes
first job do you prefer the studio album
or a live album
um if you bought a record are you a live
album i remember aerosmith bootleg was
really good great live album depends on
the artist depends it depends on the
artist yeah jose felicia
i think i like studio better good i like
the precision of studio music that is
the correct answer my friend all right
is there anybody in your family aunts
uncles cousins that you don't refer to
them as their real name like an aunt
cookie
uncle joe well all my dad's brothers my
uncles on his side they all have
nicknames you don't use albertos bersie
francisco is is uh a pancho
and gustavo's goose yeah yeah i'll have
one okay gabi gabi goose
better yes it's hard with another
country because you're like is that
garbage i think it's probably
garbage yeah what's going on down there
yeah your name is goose it's like
yeah yeah i'm talking about like an
uncle nichols or something like that
yeah
[Laughter]
no on my mother's side we only have jack
jack and his name is john okay oh that's
trash that's like the kennedys yeah
that's kennedy's yeah yeah yeah uh talk
about now
where do you keep the butter you keep it
on the counter you keep it in the fridge
in the fridge really yeah
your shoes off in the house
now people always do it and i'm like you
don't have to i don't have to you don't
have to do that too sure what about the
syrup where does that go in the cabinet
or is it in the fridge um i see when i
have it it's in the fridge maple syrup
yeah is it real maple syrup yeah
growing up was margarine sparkle whip
yes no real i didn't have butter until i
was like 22 so
the [ __ ] is
[Music]
and i had mayonnaise no yeah because
miracle whip is salad it's like dressing
miracle whip is [ __ ] trash yes the
correct answer is a nice [ __ ]
hellmann's that's right for dukes maybe
yeah her best is out that way out west
it's the same label they just changed
the name now what are you doing mail
wise mayo it's uh you know what do you
call it um are you an all top shelf
brand kind of guy um i know you're a
west side market dude right well no i
mean i like uh
you know organic food and stuff like
that okay are you doing the food
shopping i hate my kids hate it they
hate that i do that they want they want
ketchup
heinz ketchup they want you know you're
not buying heinz
well heinz now has organic ketchup
actually tastes more tomatoey you know i
like it this guy's got scrubable natural
wines organic ketchup i don't know
what's going on yeah no it's not good
it's no good
do you do the food shopping or do you
order a grocery store i do i i have for
years the last few years i've been on
the road a lot and uh there's new things
like fresh direct of course yeah so
you're doing that uh sometimes yeah okay
but no i'll go my and i have a
housekeeper she sometimes does it
honestly it's been a while but live-in
housekeeper no [ __ ] no no
she comes every day i don't care what
she does
she cleans the house i don't know i've
never seen her
i pay her
do you sleep with your socks on no hmm
have you ever left a bad yelp review
no okay oh i have recently oh tweet to
dj johnny he has to speak to the manager
a number of times
i'm an [ __ ] really well situation and
i usually end up apologizing
that's usually what happens
the last one was a hotel in stockholm it
was the grand hotel stockholm which is
like a famous hotel
and i waited an hour and 15 minutes for
room service
and i called and said where's my food
and she said it's coming and i go you
have no credibility anymore yeah yeah
you've already said this a number of
times so stop saying it
and she said i don't make the food and
i'm like all right man it's just
man what was the order you were waiting
on
chicken i was
i waited two hours
and that ketchup better be organic
sweden makes in sweden they have this
thing it's a toast with uh shrimp and
avocado and eggs on it [ __ ] good
am i allowed to curse i don't remember
oh what are you doing balls [ __ ]
can you say [ __ ] like 15 times
that was me
who did you yelp review um i'm not yelp
review but google review i i have one
for dominoes that has a lot of likes in
the story they [ __ ] up a lot of likes
and um this guy a cowboy company
it has a lot of uh it says it's very
it's a very uh well what do you call it
relevant comment gotcha people's people
write to you to say hey we appreciate it
this is a cab company
a cab company that didn't show up you
could probably find somebody's emailing
yelp reviewers just say hey man thanks
for sharing
the moses of dirt balls
it's there for us people have the power
wow
let's talk about the shower you peeing
in the shower
yeah because it's good for your uh foot
you know if you have fungus on your foot
and stuff it's good for you i think
that's a lie you tell yourself no
because i don't
[Laughter]
yeah you do yeah you leave the
toothbrush in there well a lot of times
in new york a lot of times takes a while
for the water to come in warm so i get
in there turn the water and i brush my
teeth while i'm waiting for the water to
get warm standing outside of the stream
of the water yeah huh that's kind of
psychopath yeah really yeah you're
standing in the shower not under the
water brushing your teeth naked that's
right that's pretty weird i'm not gonna
wear my clothes in the shower
when i'm waiting for the water to go i
pee in the shower 100 of the time
because i end my showers with a cold
whoosh there you go and then the cold
bush makes you piss that feels great
whoosh is good
i like your tooth fresh regular
toothbrush regular you floss it every
day i got these stick these things great
spears fantastic yeah okay for the stuff
when's the last time you were at the
dentist
uh pre-pandemic okay that's not bad
20 20
2018 something like that not bad you
uh it's been a while october of last
year so not that crazy i haven't been
since i was in my twenties i know but i
had a bad i didn't go for ten years and
i had like six forty six i can't tell
young guy you look young
oh man i'm never gonna hear the end of
that yeah
if you lose weight you'll look old real
fast you think so yeah you traded fat
for oldest i feel like genetically i
should be attractive i just try really
hard not to you are you're sexy to some
people i think yeah it's kind of a
fetish but hey i never noticed the hair
i'm just i can't take my eyes off thanks
buddy never know you know i never
noticed these
um
in the boudoir how are you sleeping how
many pillows do you use to sleep
i think yeah
like lynch bag
that's right
i got
uh usually one
and i got a couple reserved know
king-sized bed when it gets sweaty
king-size yeah king-size so you just
have one pillow under your head yeah
usually if i sometimes i read in bed and
then i end up leaving the skill then i
need the second one and i need to end up
believing that you're ready i've got
three pillows usually and one that i'm
on you read before you go to bed
yeah all right in the shower i do with
this puzzle i like uh turtles
sudoku no you're not playing candy crush
really that are you louis no no sir
thank god
it's a thing from the london times
newspaper that's called uh class hoity
toity louis ck well
i can't believe you're reading before
you guys back i read some and then but
that'll keep me up i do code it's called
code words it's it's guys i really like
stock i like uh crosswords okay and i do
those all week like in the times i do
them can you do the sunday times
crosstalk i can do i can do a whole week
in the new york times [ __ ] i like to get
the daily news
saturdays
the weekends are harder than sunday's
not hard it's just a lot
it's a volume thing how many books would
you say you've read
in my life yeah oh i don't know i don't
know over 10
yes jesus
he's a guy he's a very smart well-read i
mean he's the guy that goes to the
bookstore and buys seven books and i'll
read one of those yeah i mean i do buy
more than i
read my mother's never read a book cover
to cover really yeah and i've read maybe
three but i tell people i read a lot
i'll recommend it
i don't know
i mean you just told everybody that you
don't so stop doing that
it's a big show
yeah no i go through deserts of not
reading and then i little read a bunch
okay i i would i would peg like history
or is it fiction i like history yeah so
you're a non-fiction kind of guy i like
history for uh to listen to i like i'll
put on audiobooks about history i've
started doing that in the car it's the
best yeah but fiction uh but reading
reading fiction a lot of fiction really
i just love
uh great story great fiction i don't
read a lot of contemporary although
um what's her name white teeth is the
name of the book uh zadie smith
is currently writing she's a genius but
i like old like you know i read william
faulkner and and and uh
baldwin and all these guys old guys alex
alex baldwin wrote some great stuff
let's grow some great stuff stephen
baldwin's got a hell of a novel
steven baldwin by stephen are you a
poetry guy i can't do it i'd love to
hear it sometimes like you know if i'm
watching a movie and they quote poetry
okay i'm like i should read poetry
but i can't i somehow i can't my mind
wanders i can't get into it i always
feel like any time there's an excerpt
from a poem you're like that's beautiful
and i bought a mary oliver book and i'm
like this is trash i can't even i can't
can't make sense of it i feel it makes
me feel bad because i feel like i should
be appreciating it
i just don't have that circuit
i like this elliott e cummings is a good
one i know ee coming from the woody
allen movie and i'm like oh i gotta get
it but it's presented to you in context
you're like i based on what i just
watched or whatever well that's what i
understand this to mean that when you
have to do it on your own it's a little
yes like and that's why i read guys like
faulkner and also baldwin because they
both
have poetry and they're pro so like
there's like a thing you i can't believe
how he said that that's but i but it
means something to me because of the
person in the story just saying it
and uh i always cry at four weddings in
a funeral when he reads uh the w.h auden
poem at the when the one guy dies no
have we seen the film which one not that
four weddings at the funeral four
readings
four weddings
oh four
weddings is good is that the chris rock
i really like chris
no it's just i already can't tell a lie
somebody died at a funeral it's huge
grant right yeah hugh grant yeah
that's right i don't know about you
grant are you a cottage cheese man
and his pants do you have any on you
now again what was the last meal you
cooked and what was the last meal you
had delivered uh i made chicken parm for
my daughter and me not bad a couple
nights ago did you ever taste this
chicken parmesan
i was just telling them that i want to
make it for him cause that's his
favorite meal that's my favorite dish
ever i've been making
something we call it chicken bacon in my
house which is just you guys chicken
breast and you cut it really thin
and you dredge it and put um
bread like you know bread crumbs crumbs
yeah and that's all and with lemon and
stuff but i never occurred to me to put
red sauce sauce and some cheese
pasta and i know you're [ __ ] tits off
and it's hard to please my kid with food
and she ate two big helpings of it so i
was very proud of that last meal we
ordered out it was that
last night
what did we get uh oh this is italian i
got uh
lasagna i got a lasagna for two right
next to my scarf the whole [ __ ] thing
down and i was so sick lasagna delivered
as it did way too much lasagna yeah my
question was when's the last time you
had lasagna last night holy [ __ ]
have you ever eaten at the list
household at the list household yeah
i've had some cheerios at his house
no no no no no we've had some meals a
few meals yeah we're working on the
thing you know sarah makes cheese in the
bathtub just gonna let you know that
stay away we didn't cook for you though
no they didn't we like ordered food you
got chinese once yes
chopsticks
you know how to use chopsticks sure yeah
okay yeah it's pretty classy pretty
classy um any dental hygienist or x-ray
technicians in the family
none
nice anybody refer
anybody in your family refer to jeans as
dungarees oh that's a good one i think
my aunt
um
sue
who i love very much but she's from
texas and she didn't she married into
the family she's not a blood relative
i haven't heard a gun
where are you shopping like where
where'd you get that shirt oh that's j
crew online just j crew
your jeans where do you get your jeans
uh a place called uh alexander goldsmith
it's kind of a fancy place but jeans i
had a hard time with because really you
got to find
levi's can't do it really yeah they
either it's the leg size or they the
crotch droops and then i like fighting
them when i walk or they're just they
hurt they chafe i've got a weird body so
i walk one block in jeans and i'm in
hell so the jeans these jeans this i
mean i looked all for a long time and i
found these this brand so the jeans i
would see and they weren't i always
thought they were like walmart kind of
no
you said that like you've been watching
him from a fall
the jeans i've been seeing you in well i
did i work
i worked at a restaurant in the west
village and i would see you walking by
all the time and i worked and that's
where you looked yeah
checking that ass out
but you could always tell you i was on
uh bedford and morton where old shopsins
used to be yeah sure back to verna yeah
and you always you dress down but you
could always tell you had a little bit
of cash yeah
nice stuff cotton good cotton yeah yeah
yeah you wear a nice brown jacket and
used to wear those those blue glasses
that's right yeah real shiny oh that's
like those are you about to ask them out
of this real
[ __ ] creep level
comfortable with it
you ever wear stetson cologne yeah
what's a cologne situation i had a
french girlfriend still my dearest
friend and she gave me a bottle of
cologne once
i'm right here
i think
and it felt nice to wear it for her and
i liked the way it smite kind of liked
it but i don't wear it what deodorant do
you use none
really yeah do i smell bad are you
kidding me does he smell joe has there
ever been an issue no i've never noticed
but that's a lie you don't wear
deodorant deodorant
no what 100 never wore it in my life
you're there this mr c comes in here and
lies to my face
no deodorant damn i don't know if that's
classy i'm a secretary uh not victoria's
secret regular secret uh for the for the
ladies louis secret
hello folks uh i only got one or two
more we gotta wrap it up um if you're
going to a wedding yeah not joe because
he's a very close friend but you're
going to a wedding didn't come to my
wedding
was he invited of course ouch yep
on the road took me to paul mccartney i
made up for it uh yeah okay [ __ ]
oh god it was on record directed at a
movie
i made it for now you didn't know that
at the time you [ __ ] great news at
the time
it wasn't like you were like i can't
come to the wedding but five years from
now i'll direct a film
he might have known that he's a very
smart guy got an idiot that's all right
what can you do next wedding i don't
remember why i didn't go i should have
gone yeah or he remembers
yeah i don't know
yeah well you do this if you're at a
restaurant will you walk up to the ball
what was the question
jesus christ i forgot
how do we go to a wedding what are you
giving not to not somebody super close
to you i don't want to hear this
i'll give you that i don't want to do
this answer if you're going to a wedding
sorry joe uh you know say
what are you giving to as the gift
what's in the envelope what are you
dropping oh
jeez
let's see we've also asked every
famous person we've had in here so and
they tell the truth thousand bucks good
very good very very good
colin quinn sent me 500 for my wedding
and then a year later i went to his
wedding and sent him gave him 300.
how do you lefty for mulberry street
he had the chicken and the fish ever
been to an air show
yeah ever seen a crash at an air show no
no i saw the blue angels
yeah got a sunburn
i did really bad really bad how do you
feel about banana pudding
um it's okay it depends where you get it
but it could be okay yeah okay
can i put a question to you guys please
last night i was at a diner had soup and
then the last i slurped it up is that
bad is that garbage do you guys do that
i do that like i do that it's trash it's
yes but it's not trash if you're eating
ramen they say that's like you've got to
slurp it's part of the part of this but
at a restaurant there's no other way to
get a diner
not mike's michael's restaurant on
broadway
right there yeah actually uh yeah that's
fine that's not okay i like i like a
plate at a nice restaurant oh louie
you're not doing it at the stockholm
joint with the wine and he was drunk he
could have yeah
he takes the plate to the bathroom he's
a gentleman at the end of the day
i'm out i'm good
any bee keepers in the family no
beekeepers do you eat fast food at all
not in a long time i used to it's a long
time five ten years
we ate it in czech republic i think or
stupid one of those places no nuts yeah
it wasn't like a mcdonald's or something
no he went to mcdonald's oh yeah and
prague yes in prague beautiful
about four years ago okay ever been on a
cruise he goes
eat the crust on your pizza yeah
you drink milk with dinner
no not ever
like as a kid no i was a kid sure yeah
when's the last time you had me
meatloaf
within the last two years maybe this
guy's classy yeah
i got one last one do you have those
small disposable cups in your bathroom
small disposables
yeah like you can like drink from and
then throw out no i keep a real cup in
there
what was your first silly purchase when
you started making a lot of money back
in the day oh that's a good question for
a silly purchase like something stupid
jet ski something like that uh hot tub
i mean i bought a boat i bought a
[ __ ] yacht like a you know i mean
it's a it was like one of those that
looks like a sneaker but it was like
you know i mean it's like this wasn't
sure the one from comedians and cars
yeah yeah i bought that kind of fast i
bought that in cash like i just bought
it
i bought it with one show that's the way
i thought back then
i bought a porsche i still have it's my
one car i just bought i still have one
car i bought that's it you just have
upgrades
yeah i got it
a land rover and a jeep there you go
yeah yeah yeah but uh but the porsche is
my primary car and i still um i bought
that with my first show that i sold out
that was like a ton of money it's great
i just went and bought a porsche with
that one show and i bought a yacht with
a one show and you don't have the yacht
anymore any toys no the one the one on
jerry the one i talked about on jerry i
told you you got stuck in harlem yeah
that one is that's the one i bought like
right right away and then i and then
that one got lit it we when the
hurricane was coming the big one was
that uh sandy sandy sandy i had it i was
smart and i thought and put it up in a
parking lot but then that parking lot
was flooded and ended up in some guy's
front yard so i bought another the boat
i was on and comedian's car that was a
real serious grand bank yeah yeah that
thing was [ __ ] sweet that was a great
boat and but then that boat was uh my
vacation house for years i didn't have
like a i would just take the kids we
would live on the boat all summer that's
awesome and and that's how i discovered
shelter island where i have now that's
where i go for the summer
islands classy near greenport right
exactly right across the water here big
fan of greenport greenport's the best we
love it shelter island is between sag
harbor and greenville like the two one
ferry goes south yeah for the hamptons
sag harbor which is very fancy yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and sushi
and all that we started going greenport
is like italian ice you know beautiful
it's just and it's but it's a working
person's
it's got real jaws vibes down by the
harbor oh yeah yes it does and there's a
restaurant there called the shaky oyster
that's fantastic very good oysters yeah
good stuff
i mean it's pretty classy hey he's
classy he's louie what are you gonna say
i know he walks in both worlds he's a
classy guy
he's a classy guy
you have a favorite soda
um
you don't drink soda hard to say coke is
and nobody beats coke yeah that's right
orange crush is pretty great
orange crush when i was a kid that's
like a vacation you can't do that every
day mexico city the there you go into a
store and there's a this metal cooler
and it's filled with ice water and
there's these sodas bobbing up in it and
they're all different colors it's orange
grapes red yeah haritos but a bunch of
brands that you would they're just so
good yeah they do them nicely and
coca-cola when i was a kid was a big
we drank coke my uncle's still like if
you go to my uncle's house
um for dinner he just pours coke around
it's not you're not asking you're just
getting because it's safer than water
and it's and it's just it's warm there's
no ice
he has a big pallet of coke bottles two
liter coke but they're glass
really giant giant mexican coke bottles
are
big coke bottles yeah clean opens it up
pours everybody coke
i love coca-cola i don't i can't drink
it now it's too much sugar and i'm off
caffeine now okay but i love coke
it's great drink root beer is good too
a w
barks what are you doing either one yeah
mugs
all those are good mug sticks
yeah
ladies and gentlemen mr louis ck mr joe
list
check out the movie commentator movie
the movie
hit him again go hit go to amc go to
fandango you can find it near you yeah
just that one night don't think you
could oh gosh i'll go on the sabbath
july 6th six
years
go check it out the trailer looks
[ __ ] amazing thank you i wish you
guys the best of luck with louis thank
you so much thanks for coming joe we
absolutely love you thanks for having me
congratulations star of a [ __ ] new
movie appreciate it and he looked
[ __ ] fantastic he did a great job it
looks i can't wait to watch it
he's like gregory peck this kid yeah i
mean for real like he reminds me a
little bit of gregory peck the actually
look at that yeah peck baby
i gotta watch a tech movie
and then friday by the friday schubert
in boston saturday uh vic yeah and you
the fact that you guys are gonna be
there
we'll introduce it and we'll chat after
ron bennington is going to interview us
about the movie that's awesome yeah
great congratulations nice to meet you
appreciate you guys thanks guys thank
you thank you
gang we will see you next week peace
peace